Republicans changing the political
landscape in what was once a swing state
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and
Senator Marco Rubio utterly destroying
their Democratic opponents and it wasn't
even close DeSantis taking a Victory lap
after crushing Charlie Chris by close to
20 points and winning deep blue
Miami-Dade County by 11 points that is a
40-point swing from when Hillary Clinton
took the same county in 2016.
we saw freedom in our very way of life
and so many other jurisdictions in this
country Wither on the vine Florida held
the LIE we chose facts over fear we
chose education over indoctrination we
chose Law and Order over rioting and
disorder we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob Florida is where wolf goes
to die people have come here because our
policies work
leadership matters
all right boy that was a rousing speech
Jesse I mean people in Florida love him
they love the guy and he won by less
than a percent the first time and now
he's winning by 20. that is a blowout
name the guy that he beat Gilly yes
remember that yeah
naked on the ground with a drug with
drugs all over yep what's wrong with
that
Saturday night in gutfelter so this
guy's a miracle and I don't think you've
ever seen a republican blow out that big
in the State of Florida because he came
and everybody said he was killing people
when he kept the schools and the
business open and he kept it open ended
up being right he sent migrants to you
know Martha's Vineyard he put the
Democrats on defense there and he's
winning Cubans in Miami-Dade he's
swimming Puerto Ricans in Orlando and
he's even winning Rich liberal Democrats
who winter in Palm Beach he won Palm
Beach County which is astounding and you
know even her hear about the hurricane
anymore do you you don't even hear about
it because he's he's got that state to
recover so well he actually won by a
bigger margin than Gavin Newsom won in
California so if if he wants his
political future is very bright he's got
a lot of political capital I don't think
he's going to get in this primary with
Trump I think it's going to be too
bloody but uh if he waits you know the
the show is his and you know Dana
there's a lot to be said about the the
Miami-Dade and it looks like basically a
new Coalition I mean the Cubans the
Hispanics and it in addition to a
coalition I mean what you've got now is
the more generic the bigger issue is
that people are now voting based upon
what their needs are and not based upon
their ethnicity yes so I think that that
was interesting so the last Republican
to win as a gubernatorial candidate
Miami-Dade was Jeb Bush in 2002 and he
had spent much of his time in his life
there that was his home base like so he
knew a lot of the people this is quite
remarkable what Rhonda Santos has done
because no other Republican had been
able to do that and until this moment he
has a 64 approval rating across the
state I mean you can't even get 64
percent of the people to agree on a
Mother's Day resolution right now so
that's actually pretty impressive and
then he just exudes confidence and
competence but I think that the new
Coalition and the continuing realignment
that I'm super interested in as we live
through it is that you have these people
who are living there saying I don't want
to vote based on where I came from I'm
going to vote based on what my
opportunity is here what's the
opportunity for my kids did they get to
go to school do they have opportunity
here for educational educational
attainment and they want freedom and
that's what Florida was suggesting I do
Wonder however if enough New Yorkers
left
and went to Florida and hurt Lee zeldin
yes yes at the end that's great that's a
great thought I mean I thought that too
I said you know maybe they're down there
and that's why we're losing up here but
what about jensaki saying that that part
of the reason for the win is that it was
due to Spanish language disinformation
in Florida what's she talking about
I don't know Florida is over for
Democrats that's just the reality of it
and we're going to pick up a couple
seats that you know there's a great
story with the 25 year old who won a
seat down there as the youngest person
ever elected to congress that's exciting
um but there are other places to be
spending our money and our efforts you
know States like Arizona North Carolina
Sherry Beasley ran a really great race
lost to Ted Bud by about three points
um Georgia and I think that we have to
in general look for different
opportunities and for me personally it
was the senate race in Marco Rubio it
should be said also was an incredible
performance Val demmings is a star right
and she's someone who was a top my list
for VP candidates for Joe Biden and I
think
um you know obviously he won with komal
I think he would have won with Val
demmings as well and I hate that she's
in a state where it looks like she
wouldn't be able to win Statewide office
because I think she's an absolute
treasure and she says all the best
things about the Democratic party former
police chief
um tough on crime but kind to people
wanting for
um reforms but you know doesn't have the
usual weakness thing that people she
also gave up her seats so she's kind of
nowhere now right nowhere now yes um she
will be somewhere I mean Val damnings
we'll figure it out um but that was I
thought that was a real Democratic loss
last night based on the quality of that
person and the candidate
um and that campaign it was a wonderful
campaign yeah and certainly not to deny
Rubio I mean the incredible win that he
had uh but but what about the census's
speech I mean when you listen to that
speech and I listen to the whole thing I
mean he's not just talking to Floridians
he's talking to all human beings I want
to talk about Charlie Christ
retire to that strip mall tanning booth
you know return to the Coppertone lab
where they created him I mean he's got
to get the message that he's about as
popular as a gender Studies major in
preschool it's not going to happen so
this is the most amazing thing about him
he ran as a republican he ran as a
Democrat and he's run it as an
independent right so there's nothing
left he is official it's pronoun
officially is a they they must go away
where are you gonna go what are you
gonna do next I hate these people that
just keep running and running and
running and just because they lose they
think no that actually elevates me it
gets my name yeah it's like if I run for
president more people are going to know
me I just I just love that he got
clobbered I wish it was more
didn't work out for you no not at all
yeah did you have any faith that he
would win
Chris hey Chris yeah no no I don't think
anyone really no I think he was exactly
and he was happy to do it okay yes
exactly all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else